[Musique]
grosse nouvelle dans le monde des
télécommunications manon brouillette ex
pdg de vidéos temps est nommé chef de
l'exploitation numéro deux de la
division consommateurs du géant
américain verizon c'est la deuxième plus
grande entreprise de télécommunications
aux états unis avec nous ce soir manon
brouillette bonsoir félicitations madame
brouillé pour cette nomination qui vous
amène dans l'une des plus grandes
entreprises de télécommunications dans
le monde et la division consommateurs
que vous allez diriger c'est quand même
70 % des revenus de l'entreprise à peu
près 90 milliards de dollars américains
et vous arrivez je vois sourire vous
arrivez à un moment où on devait oui
exactement comment vous prenez votre
mandat premièrement je me sens
privilégié cc je m'aime moi j'étais un
peu stressé comme exceptionnel pour un
jour une personne du canada comme moi
qui ai la mauricie qui se retrouve
effectivement dans la plus grande télé
comme quasiment au monde donc
donc je pars excité puis je pense que
vous l'avez bien dit j'arrive juste au
bon timing
quand on regarde c'est au sortir de la
dernière enchère de balle c'est ils ont
doublé leurs capacités spectrale donc
mojo dans une organisation
exceptionnelle l'as réal aurait 7 à jour
de la saint léger donc va pouvoir
vraiment mettre à contribution toutes
mes compétences mes capacités puis
pratiquement sans limite leur combat
dans des organisations de cette
envergure
un autre chiffre qui donne le vertige
c'est la capitalisation boursière de
verizon qui est de 235 milliards de
dollars américains c'est plus gros que
n'importe quelle entreprise en bourse au
canada
expliquez-nous ce qui vous amène chez
verizon et ce qui amène verizon à faire
appel à votre expertise vous faites moi
ce qui m'amène la basse et vous
comprendrez qu'un processus comme ça
c'est pas faire en 24 heures a été
plusieurs
amen processus rigoureux et moi j'étais
mal gré on peut être impressionné on
pourrait se lancer là dedans les yeux
fermés mais c'est pas été du tout mon
approche parce que je suis je suis
sérieuse dans ma démarche je m'assurer
de bien faire le travail donc j'étais
rigoureuse dans mon analyse c'est moi ce
qui m'amène la bosse est clairement je
dirais la culture la position très
innovant de cette organisation là tous
les égards pendant le produit mais dans
les pratiques de ressources humaines
c'est une équipe tellement diversifiée
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de femmes au
leadership dans les fonctions de haut
calibre représentation des minorités
visibles à tous les égards donc tous ces
petits éléments là pour moi m'ont
beaucoup beaucoup excité au cours de mon
évaluation et moi je pense qu est ce qui
ce qui m'a démarquer probablement parce
qu'il y avait plusieurs candidats de
partout dans le monde donc c'est très
honnêtement au départ chute à vélo par
curiosité mais j'étais présent blement
je me disais si c'est c'est presque
impossible parce que j'aimerais quand
même une business de moins de 4
milliards on se comprend et là vous avez
dit les chutes tout à l'heure c'est
assez impressionnant mais je pense que
c'est cesser mon authenticité c'est ma
capacité si quand on travaille dans des
plus petites organisations de comprendre
vraiment le 3,60 et vidéotron devrait
pas assez puisque je dois souligner le
grand leadership de mon prédécesseur
robert dépatie qui est des moments où on
était très innovant l'expérience client
tout ce qu'on a accompli dans les
transformations ne soit et des premiers
dans l'industrie donc ce aussi bien sur
comme j'ai contribué à ce ma feuille de
route est parlé par elle même temps
qu'est ce que dit ce que lâche gérard
eason a des visées au canada je me
permets de poser cette question
non c'est une bonne question mais c'est
pas du tout l'objectif
dans ce contexte là que je les rejoins
pas du tout écouter ils ont comme jeudi
attend tous la cantate acheté pour plus
de 50 milliards de spect l'autre de
maximiser sur ton propre marché au
départ
donc je pense que c'est là qu'on se
concentrer que ça pas du tout été
question dans les discussions vous
entrez dans un club sélect madame
brouillette parce que on a parlé à
quelques reprises à patrick pichette par
exemple qui qui a été chez google on a
parlé à jean raby qui a été chez natixis
qui avaient été vus pour diriger la
caisse de dépôt de ces québécois qui
accèdent à des postes extrêmement
important à l'étranger aux états unis
qu'est ce que ça vous fait d'atteindre
sa d'arriver à ça mais je me suis pas
vraiment arrêtée à sa place et plus la
réaction j'ai d'être tout le monde qui
m'écrit aujourd'hui puis c'est vraiment
après cinq sens que je dis là tout
comprendre quand on entre dans un
processus comme ça qu'on accepte un job
de cette période on s'est séparé de
poster dans le club sélect et tu parais
plus ça est ce que je suis capable de
faire la job donc
donc c'est sûr qu'avec la réaction que
j'ai aujourd'hui t je suis je suis
heureuse
seppi qui je pense que je suis heureuse
pour les femmes parce que j'étais la
seule femme dans tout le line up
permettez-moi anglicismes c'est moi quel
job puis oui c'est vrai cette image
tellement gros donc moi j'arrive un peu
comme si je rentre ça normal vous n'avez
jamais visité l'école donc c'est donc on
va y aller par étape mais certains cas
c'est la priorité c'est vraiment de
rentrer et de dominer dans la salle j on
ne tous les actifs pour passe donc d'un
point de vue stratégique que ça va être
mon focus ça va être aussi on donne le
mandat de poursuivre la transformation
numérique qui était amorcée au sein
d'organisations pour ça que je rentre
comme ma chef de l'exploitation parce
que je veux ma ferrer davantage à voir
on est vraiment dans un modèle
d'affaires qu'on appelle ovni canal on a
des centres d'appels des points de vente
physiques
le commerce en ligne donc il faut
s'assurer qu'une synergie pour le client
dans tout ça et ça c'est un immense défi
donc ça c'est je dirais mes objectifs à
un cours moyen
m et puis a par la suite je vais je vais
certainement saez a plein d'opportunités
parce que je suis quelqu'un qui
développent puisque quelqu'un qui saisit
les opportunités au passage puis je
vienne à l'identique et certainement au
cours des prochains mois est ce que vous
auriez pu vous retrouver dans une
entreprise au canada après avoir dirigé
vidéotron comment se fait-il qu'on vous
a pas retrouvées par exemple chez bell
et que là vous vous retrouvez aux états
unis avec cette grande entreprise
ben là des opportunités qui passe je
dirais un bel est un super bonne
position il ya un pdg ont préparé un
plan de succession c'est opportunités ne
s'est pas passé puis je pense que je
suis pas certain que j'aurais été à
l'aise d'aller concurrencer que dix
autres ont d autres ans c'est un peu
comme mon bébé et j'étais là presque 15
ans j'ai de l'affection pour toutes mes
employés j'ai eu plein de messages
aujourd'hui de leur parti ils sont fiers
que je m'en aille laborieusement les
représenter parce que je vais porter
avec moi tout mon acquis mes compétences
développées chez vidéotron donc je pense
que c'est une question d'opportunité qui
pense qui celle-là je veux dire c'est un
coup de coeur
cc c'est un défi qui va me permettre de
me développer
j'ai le vertige un peu là donc c'est
parfait a dans la jeune cinquantaine
devait pas encore comme ça aux boutiques
ses orteils comme on dit alors c'est
tout s'est tous mis ensemble qui fait
que pour moi c'est une opportunité
extraordinaire super super
reconnaissante pour mais choisis puis
super excité puis emballé parce qu'ici
matin je vous souhaite bonne chance
manon brouillette merci beaucoup à la
prochaine merci pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne i
cirdi